we have different views sometimes but
that's my husband
you know as kim kardashian and kanye
west
continue to face rumors of marital
troubles a source tells et
that the reality star is extremely
stressed out
kim and kanye are trying their best to
keep their relationship issues a private
matter
especially for the sake of the kids the
source adds that kim
is quote extremely stressed out from
taking care of their children
studying to become a lawyer and figuring
out her situation with kanye in the best
way possible for both their kids
and for him and his mental state quote
she is doing her best to hold it
together
but it has been overwhelming like that's
not stuff
we put on social media speculation that
kim and kanye could be heading for a
split
sparked in january and a source told et
earlier this month that while kim is
prepared to divorce kanye
she isn't rushing through the process
and wants what's best for the family
i always know his heart according to
that source
the pair is on solid and amicable terms
though kim is ready for any decision she
needs to make
especially when it comes to the
well-being of the four children they
share
seven-year-old north five-year-old saint
three-year-old chicago and one-year-old
psalm
i feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
and while kim and kanye may be heading
towards a split
kim's younger sister khloe kardashian
and her beau
tristan thompson are seemingly mending
old wounds
i don't even think it's to her anymore
about like getting over the past like
things that you guys have been through i
think it's just mostly what other people
are going to think
yeah i don't even i think she's totally
fine otherwise she won't be hanging out
with you 24 7.
yeah yeah in a new clip from the
upcoming 20th and final season of
keeping up with the kardashians
kim gives the nba star a little advice
about getting back together with coco
following tristan's 2019 infidelity and
their subsequent split honestly i just
think that you should talk to her
you should just tell her like you don't
want to rush her process
but if you were to just like explain to
her that you don't want to be
this like kept secret because she is so
embarrassed
like that makes you sad and that makes
you
you know feel away yeah we'll see what
happens
yeah will keep me posted no i will i
will
fans can watch the couple's journey on
keeping up with the kardashians which
returns to e
on march 18th